go go is going Hog Wild over
International bacon day coming up this
Saturday so joining us from Hash House
is Brandon Reese to talk all about well
Every Day's Bacon day every day is
making a day of Hash House yes but you
guys do have some special things going
on we do we're going to celebrate Friday
and Saturday
um we're giving we're doing our bacon
bacon bacon for five bucks it's usually
12. so come on in and get a bacon bacon
this is three types of bacon yeah we got
Hash House seasoning brown sugar and
peppercorn and it is each one's a little
different okay spicy Savory I think I
just sweet this feels like the maple oh
yeah and then we've got our BLT Mary's
here so BLT Mary's we've got our BB BLT
bacon sandwich
what is a BLT Mary
bacon lettuce the bacon is in the drink
yeah right there boom wow okay and we've
got the best Bloody Marys and then we've
got our bacon waffle so we actually cook
the bacon right into the waffle lay it
right into the batter and then go enjoy
I so love this and you guys opened up
your first one on Sahara how long ago uh
2005 2005. since that time and even you
got through the pandemic and did you're
opening up what nine ten stores now yeah
we're opening Atlantic City on Tuesday
and then we're opening one at Disney in
early November Orlando just we'll make
nine to ten yeah Orlando wow that's
fantastic congratulations
yeah that used to be the islands
locations right across from the Red
Rocks yeah he's doing great and uh
servicing a Summerlin area oh man and if
you haven't been to Hash House it is so
unique and it is so good chicken waffles
always one of my favorites there what
are your favorites I gotta go with the
sage-fried chicken Benedict the man the
Adam Richmond man versus food special he
did there that one's that one's one of
my favorite that's where we get a lot of
people coming in and asking but we can
do great Flapjacks great scrambles and
great ashes oh man that is so good all
right so you got the five dollar special
this just bacon right just pure bacon I
mean almost we've got so much bacon in
there really every day is bacon day but
we just want to do something special and
kind of uh you know remind people yeah
what got you started into this line of
cooking uh what you know the bacon the
the it's southern comfort food yeah and
it's our our co-founder was from Indiana
so you mix you know a California I came
with an Indiana Southern Comfort boom
Twisted Farm food so good it is comfort
food it is sure it is comfortable you
gotta come hungry uh we'll feed you
we'll do the dishes and yeah
that's worse yeah just eat and cut you
can go so how many locations in and
around Las Vegas now we've got six here
now we've got uh the Rio link and the
Plaza Hotels and then one at Henderson
Sahara and Rainbow which you know really
well and then Summerlin they won over by
Red Rock yeah my picture's still up
there it is still that's that's it I
moved it up to the front I know I heard
it was in the bathroom no no no no no
all right ready it's good to see you
yeah it's good to see you uh
International bacon celebration going on
this